hey dr. Burke here in this short video
we're going to talk about how to warm up
your hands or your feet using
acupressure to the thyroid now I'm just
going to make a disclaimer I'm not
curing thyroid disease okay I'm just
showing you how to influence the thyroid
to warm up the hands and feet it works
about 50% of the time so I'm going to
show you how to do it on yourself or
have someone do it on you if it doesn't
work chances are that the reason why
you're cold is coming from another
source
okay so there's many different causes of
cold hands or feet so first thing you
want to do is rate the coldness so let
me just see you have yeah you do have
cold hands I'm going to rate her
coldness on a scale from one to ten ten
being very very very very hot zero being
ice cold give me a number how are we
going to rate that temperature high but
okay now we're doing on our hands you
would do it on the feet separately so
we're going to work on the hands first
okay so I'm going to turn it this way
and the acupressure points to the
thyroid are located right here and if
you wanted to know the segments
so that's c5 c6 area right here so now
I'm taking my two fingers right here and
this is course someone else doing this
you're going to take your hand in the
forehead
and press down here straight like this
okay like scissors of course it if there
is an issue here it might be a little
sore so go light but I'm going to press
right in here and the most important
thing is we don't mess up their hair
okay so now I'm pressing on this point
right here and I'm just going to hold
this for about an hour now I'm just
kidding we're going to hold it for a
couple minutes here so I'm pressing
right into this little point right here
and you're going to feel a little kind
of a resistance and I'm just holding an
equal amount of pressure at the area of
the lower neck okay so it's right
through here
right about there and so now while I'm
doing this I'm going to ask the person
that five tell me when it goes to a six
six okay good now I'm just holding this
sustained pressure and it could take
about two minutes okay so now tell me
when it's a seven
seven okay good tell me when it's an
eight
good it's an 8 let me just see here yeah
for warming up nicely now what you may
want to do let's say for example it's
going to slow then you might want to
move your fingers down just half an inch
okay because you want to get the exact
opposite of the thyroid gland so you
want to get the exact opposite if you
draw a circle around where the thyroid
is which is in the front of the neck and
the lower part so I'm going to come down
here like down at c6 which is the last
one of the last segments before c7 which
is very lower so we're going to just
hold that right there now what's
interesting when I went down here a
little lower her forehead just heated up
so there's something happening here
because it's not me okay what is it is
it what's happening now to the
temperature okay she said the palms of
her hand are warm now so it wasn't a 5
what is the palm of your hands right now
a 9 so that's pretty cool so now we're
going to do if you don't have someone to
do this on you you can use this
do-it-yourself
version and we're going to use on
someone
this small we're going to use this with
right here sometimes we'd use a bigger
one but I'm going to actually just this
is a tripod so I'm going to set this
back here and once you scoot your butt
this way about six inches yeah now look
at this so I'm going to actually
position this let me just take the hair
out of the way here and just give me
that scissors over there so we're going
to come right down here just sit up for
a second okay good when I hit this right
here alright so now just kind of lean
your head back there yeah do you feel
this is the same pressure that I did
okay I do I have to go lower
right there how was that so now we're
going to do is I'm going to take this I
try to have her lean back a little bit
like this and let gravity pull her head
back so now we have an acupressure
device that's exactly at the lower neck
pressing on those two points for about
two or three minutes that way no one is
the pressure she can just lay back let
gravity push her head back on this
device and the longer she does it the
warmer she's going to get so this is
great to do especially if you have to go
to sleep in you it's hard to sleep
because your your hands or feet are so
cold so this is just something you can
do see if it works
it may work I say it's about 50% so give
it a shot and I will see you in the next
video